[Music]
dear friends
2021 is nearing its end
very soon time will carry us from the
past to the future
it is something that happens every day
minute and second
but we hear this ceaseless march of time
clearest of all on new year's eve
we anticipate it is an important
milestone
we are all
we understand that it cannot be
separated from the events of the year
that has just passed
we have been met with colossal
challenges but we have learned to live
in these harsh conditions to solve
difficult problems we have managed to do
so thanks to our solidarity
together we continue to fight a
dangerous epidemic which has engulfed
every continent and is still to subside
the insidious disease has taken tens of
thousands of lives i want to offer words
of sincere support to those who have
lost their relatives and loved ones
the most important thing is that we
fought the challenges of this year
together
we protected those who found themselves
in a difficult situation
first of all we supported older people
and families with children who are the
future of russia
we consistently promoted our interest
and the security of our country and our
people
and are now starting to tackle strategic
development tasks
of course numerous problems remain
unsolved but we have completed this year
with commendable results
and the credit here is mainly due to you
the citizens of russia
it is dear friends the fruit of your
hard work
every one of you in your respective
roles worked to carry out your duty to
do what you can and even much more to
help those having the hardest time
a heartfelt thank you to all of you
in difficult times like now it is
especially important to have a
constructive mindset to strive to
realize your personal goals and help
society and your country
on new year's eve we hope the new year
will bring new opportunities
we trust our luck but understand that
our fate is in our hands
it is our priorities what we do on a
daily basis
how devoted we are to what we do
and how persistent we are in achieving
success
our national plans realisation depends
on the success of each of us
that we can move forward and ensure the
prosperity
this night is full of warm feelings and
good intentions
everybody wants to show their best side
and this open and generous atmosphere is
the spirit of this holiday when we want
to give our parents our attention and
care
to embrace them if they are near and
tell our loved ones that we love them
we are blessed with being in love having
children a family and friends
all of these are fundamental values
they are the greatest things any of us
have
in our lives
and genuinely say that we love them
to make our hearts more sensitive and
trusting generous and merciful
wherever you may be in this moment
among your family and friends
in the squares of cities dear to you
everywhere we hear
i am happy to join those wishes and
would like to wish happy new year
especially to those on duty both civil
and military
to those saving lives protecting us from
external and internal threats
operating transportation lines
certain industries and utilities
hundreds of thousands of our compatriots
are involved in these fears
and in many russian families including
those abroad
traditional happy new year greetings
will be heard
these simple words resonate with us
especially well because they are passed
down from generation to generation
i congratulate you with all my heart
most of all i wish you good health
and that will help you succeed in your
work study art and hobbies
i wish that every family has more happy
events
that more families are created that more
children are born and that they grow up
to be healthy smart honest and free
let love be in every heart and inspire
us to achieve our goals and mount the
highest summits
those we love
and are great and only motherland
happy new year dear friends happy 20-22
[Music]
[Applause]
hello
[Music]
is
yes
[Music]
[Applause]
oh
[Music]
is
oh
[Music]
is
[Applause]
[Music]
you